Enough talk about canvases and memes, let's go ahead and start making one.
Right here I've got an HTML document which we'll be using to create the canvas.
In order to have a canvas, we need to use the canvas tag, which looks like so.
The canvas tag takes optional width and
height parameters to allocate some space on the web page for the canvas.
Like you had canvas in the real world, this canvas tag alone is
only going to give us the physical space on the website to work with.
We actually need to take a few more steps to get an object that we
can use for drawing.
To use a canvas, we need to access it from our JavaScript code
which I've included between these two script tags after the canvas.
We'll start by grabbing the canvas using this selector to
get the canvas with the id of C from the body.
And then from the canvas, we need to grab its context.
So to do that we'll simply call the method; get context,
on the canvas that we've created, and we have to pass in this perimeter for 2D.
You might wonder here if we can grab the 2D canvas,
could we also grab a 3D canvas?
In fact we can, but that's not what this course is about.
So we're going to focus on 2D canvases.
From here, we can actually start calling methods on this context to start
drawing on our canvas